here at eight news now we know the
rising price of well just about
everything including gas groceries it's
all impacting all of us and our viewers
and we want to be here to help out to
give back to our community so eight news
now is partnering with albertsons to
help gift you a good day every week
we'll be surprising lucky shoppers and
helping to pay for their groceries let's
take a look at how i surprised one
albertson's shopper
i met janelle at the albertsons near
silverado ranch she told me it's hard to
keep up with the cost of living our
wages stay the same but all the prices
keep going up that's especially
challenging when she's entertaining
family too we have kids and grandkids
and you know
brothers sister-in-laws you know
everybody comes over to our house you
have to buy groceries but it's just you
just have to be more cautious nowadays
janelle says she looks for ways to help
ease the cost of her bills you have to
look for like coupons and what's on sale
and i mean there's certain things that
you still want to buy that you know you
like but other than that it's just
whatever's on sale that's when we
decided it was time to gift her a good
day eight news now in albertsons would
like to gift you a good day and we'd
like to take care of your groceries
today nice that's very nice thank you
would that help a little bit that
definitely would help congratulations we
hope it helps just a little bit
connie's going to
take it off your hands thank you so much
well as you heard janelle they feed a
lot of people in their household she was
very happy had a great time surprising
her and you never know it could be you
next keep an eye out for the good day
team and maybe you'll be the next person
to be gifted a good day so janelle
later came back she she came back to us
and she said look guys i'm so sorry i'm
so camera shy i was really just kind of
frozen
and she goes i hope you realize just how
much i truly do appreciate this
you know some people cry some people hug
you i mean everybody's got their own
reactions right but she truly wanted us
to know how much it's going to help them
and
she said you just people don't get
surprised very often and it was super
super nice well think about it she was
like you know in the middle of running
errands she's got i got to go to the
grocery store then the dry cleaner to
the gas station all sudden here you come
with a big fake credit card like here
we're gonna pay for your stuff it'll
throw your equilibrium off this little
bit a little bit it wasn't fake it was
super sized okay super excited okay fair
enough
well i'm glad she was happy that's
awesome that's all that matters and
we're so glad we could help you betcha